my name is Rajiv single eres I'm from
alcatel-lucent I run the business for
the company in Asia and I'm the chairman
of the ICT Agenda Council we just
finished a small session with Anton
sushi discussing what's happening in
Burma and was happening in the world and
she is an extraordinary woman sense of
humor a sense of humanity a sense of
real person came out into session she
emphasized that education is the biggest
challenge in Burma and a lack of
education at the youngest level in
primary schools in particular so there's
a lot of talk about the importance of
secondary education a lot of talk about
advanced degrees which would she really
emphasized was the need to focus on
primary education and it was very moving
and you could tell everyone in the room
was excited even one of the minister's
asked for photograph real time so it was
it was fun it was a very good session
and one session that hopefully will set
the tone for an extraordinarily
and enjoyable and informative conference